من بين العديد من العملاء الالمانيين جمع
كارل لودي معلومات حساسه عن النشاط
العسكري للغرب وكادت رسائله ان تغير مجرى
الحرب العالميه الاولى لولا ثغره صغيره
كلفته ثمنا باهظا فما قصته ولد كارل
هانزلودي في برلين عام
1877 وعاش طفوله قاسيه حيث توفي والده قبل
ان يتم الثامنه ليدخل دارا للعتام عندما
اصبح في السادسه عشره وجد عملا كصبي
مقصوره بسفينه شراعيه كما درس بالاكاديميه
البحريه التي اهلته للانضمام للقوات
البحريه حصل كارل لاحقا على رخصه قبطان
تجاري فانضم للاسطول التجاري دون ان يفقد
موقعه في الاحتياط البحري ما سمح له
بالسفر على متن سفن الانجليزيه والنرويجيه
والام اثناء رحلاته التقى كارل بامريكيه
ثريه وخطط معها للاستقرار في الولايات
المتحده لكن الزواج انتهى بعد ثلاثه اشهر
بصفقه مع والدها الذي منحه عشره الاف
دولار مقابل تطليقها بعد ذلك عاد كارل الى
برلين وعاش حياه مرفهه وطلب التسريح بحجه
اصابته بمرض فعرض عليه مسؤولون مخابرات
البحريه العمل لديهم بدات مهمته بالتجسس
على القوات الغربيه في جنوب فرنسا حيث زود
بلاده بمعلومات عسكريه وافره عن العدو قبل
شهرين من بدء الحرب العالميه الاولى منح
كارل جواز سفر امريكي باسم تشارلز
وارسل الى اسكتلندا ثم الى الدنمارك
لتقديم تقرير عن التحركات العسكريه في
القواعد البحريه بادمبرا
كانت وسيله كارل للتواصل مع رؤساء في
المانيا ارسال البرقيه الى البلدان
المحايده فارسل عددا منها الى عنوان مكشوف
لدى المخابرات البريطانيه في ستوكهولم
سمح لاول رسالتين بالوصول الى الالمان ثم
حجبت الرسائل التي احتوت على معلومات
عسكريه حساسه في بدايه اكتوبر عام
1914 قبض على كارل ومثل امام محكمه عسكريه
بريطانيه حيث كان الجاسوس الوحيد الذي
احتجز في المملكه المتحده في فتره ما بين
الحربين العالميتين في فجر السادس من
نوفمبر اعدم كار رميا بالرصاص في برج لندن
في اول اعدام يحدث على البرج منذ 167 عاما
ظلت يتردد كخائن في بريطانيا لكن الحزب
النازي كرمه كبطل قومي بمجرد وصوله للسلطه
واقيمت له النصب التذكاريه واحتفالات
التابين كما بقيت الفعاليه القوميه
الالمانيه
تحيي ذكراه حتى اليوم